eingelagert bei minus 196 grad celsius
und statt blut frostschutzmittel in den
arterien und irgendwann wenn die
forschung so weit ist lässt man sich auf
1000 wieder zum leben erwecken
nein das ist kein science fiction
sondern der plan vieler menschen
ihr habt euch dieses krasse thema
whatsapp gewünscht und bekommt jetzt
alle facts dazu wie weit ist die
forschung zur chronik welche
herausforderung gibt es und werden wir
vielleicht bald ewig leben können jetzt
den klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
vielen dank für diesen themenvorschlag
und wie ihr mir auch bei whatsapp oder
den anderen messengern themenvorschläge
machen könnte das erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos einfrieren auftauen und
einfach weiterleben statt zu sterben
ging mal wieder nach science-fiction pur
wird aber vielleicht bald realität oder
nicht das thema ist hochaktuell
dabei hat sich der erste mensch schon
vor gut 50 jahren nach seinem tod
einfrieren lassen die leiche vom
amerikaner james beckford liegt seit
januar 1964 gut gekühlt bei minus 190
grad in einem mitteilten
er selbst aber auch seine anhänger gehen
fest davon aus dass er eines tages
wieder leben wird teams aus
medizinerinnen und medizinern dagegen
sehen das ganze etwas kritischer viele
halten es für komplett unrealistisch vor
allem in dem fall bedford denn
schließlich wurde er vor 50 jahren noch
mit einer ganz anderen technik
eingefroren als heute der fachbegriff
für das ganze laut chronik und selbst
heute gibt es technisch gesehen noch
viele herausforderungen das größte
problem sind wohl die kristalle die sich
beim einfrieren im körper bilden in
bedford fall wurde seinem blut deswegen
auch durch frostschutzmittel ersetzt
damit sein gewebe nicht zerplatzt wie
eine flasche die man im tiefkühlschrank
vergessen hat anhänger der kryonik
berufen sich in ihrem glauben oft auf
den fall der schwedin anna bergen
sie stürzte bei einem unfall unter die
eisdecke eines flusses und konnte erst
eine stunde später gerettet werden durch
eine luftblase konnte sie zwar atmen
doch sie war klinisch tot
es konnten keine ihren aktivitäten
gemessen werden sie atmete nicht und
ihre körpertemperatur lag unter 14 grad
celsius das ärzte-team reanimierte sie
wärmte das blut auf und schlossen sie an
einer herz kreislauf maschine an und
tatsächlich an erwarte auf und es
blieben keine bleibende schäden der
grund dafür ihr gehirn wurde sehr
schnell abgekühlt und wurde so in einem
unbeschädigten zustand konserviert
inzwischen setzen viele forschungsteams
einen ähnliche technik ein um
operationen am herzen durchzuführen doch
zurück zum fall bedford er war gestorben
an einem tumor und genau das ist das
nächste problem denn selbst wenn
forschungsteams ist in der zukunft
schaffen könnten seinen kompletten
organismus wieder zu beleben würde der
sterbevorgang absolut sofort wieder
einsetzen um das zu vermeiden müssen
irgendwie
alle zellen verjüngt werden wie auch
immer man das schaffen will ja und ein
ähnliches szenario das hat sich auch ein
14 jähriges mädchen aus london
entstünden bericht hat sie durchgesetzt
dass sie nach ihrem tod eingefroren wird
wenn sie pocht auf ihr recht auf ein
späteres leben wenn des forschungsteams
irgendwann einmal gelungen sein sollte
den krebs zu therapieren dazu die junge
briten
ich glaube die konservierung durch einen
frieden gibt mir die chance geheilt und
wieder aufgeweckt zu werden und wenn es
erst in hunderten von jahren ist konkret
funktioniert die technik so die
menschlichen körper werden auf minus 196
grad heruntergekühlt und in behälter mit
flüssigem stickstoff gelagert ähnlich
wie auch in dem fall bedford vor 50
jahren wird das blut ersetzt durch eine
spezielle kühlflüssigkeit um zu
verhindern dass zellen beschädigt werden
das gewebe wird schlagartig herunter
gekühlt damit sich keine eiskristalle
bilden die zellen verletzen könnten
das gewebe wird so zu einer brüchigen
glasartige substanz die unternehmen in
russland und den usa beispielsweise die
diese technik derzeit anbieten konzerns
konzentrieren sich meist auf die
perfekte konservierung des gehirns als
dem wichtigsten menschlichen organ alles
andere wäre kaum zu stemmen dann müsste
man nämlich in jedem zelltyp ein anderes
spezielles frostschutzmittel einsetzen
die anhänger der kryonik gehen davon aus
dass künstlich hergestelltes
biologisches material in zukunft alle
anderen körperstrukturen ersetzen kann
die kosten eingefroren in tiefkühl
behältern gelagert zu werden sind nicht
ohne in russland kostet das bis zu
150000 euro sparen kann man wenn man nur
19 organe oder im kopf einfriert
rechtlich gesehen ist es in deutschland
nicht möglich langfristig eingelagert zu
werden denn das gilt als bestattung doch
es geht schon tatsächlich um
funktioniert auch nur nicht mit
ausgewachsenen menschen sondern
mitteilen im kleinen rahmen geht chronik
nämlich oder eine art chronik nämlich
sogar in deutschland beispielsweise gibt
es in leipzig ein unternehmen dass
stammzellen von neugeborenen ein fred
3400 euro kostet das für 25 jahre
falls also bei dem menschen später in
seinem leben mal ein knorpel abgenutzt
sein sollte können aus den eingefrorenen
stammzellen neuer knorpel gezüchtet
werden das fazit zur chronik ist also
durchwachsen die meisten seriösen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
halte es für quatsch dass menschen
eingefroren und aufgebaut werden um dann
einfach weiterzuleben selbst in der
zukunft sei das technisch kaum zu
realisieren
selbst die vielen anhänger der chronik
selbst halten eine erfolgreiche
reanimation in der zukunft für eher
unwahrscheinlich sie schätzen die
wahrscheinlichkeit bei dem aktuellen
technischen know how bei etwa fünf
prozent
naja aber ist ja schon mal was mal sehen
ob die chancen in zukunft steigen wenn
ihr zu den ersten gehören wollte die
neueste zu erfahren dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp wenn ihr
wollt könnt ihr euch auch mit mir über
telegrammen instagram oder den facebook
messenger verknüpfen dann erfahrt ihr
von mir vor allen andern vom neuesten
video tag nicht garantiert ihr könnt
dort direkt über mich in der redaktion
von links und mitmachen und zum beispiel
themen vorschlagen einfach hier
draufklicken und zur begrüßung habe ich
ein kleines goodie für euch im
begrüßungstext versteckt nur natürlich
nicht das aber mit der genau mit der
glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter
dafür auch draufklicken ist der tod
tödlich oder leben wir weiter ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran